yes that big move today season two guys
it's so weird right yeah you're right
yeah we are literally going to do season
two soon that's so weird yeah I'm
excited confusing but it's great a lot
of some very positive about the very you
guys heard from people or had fans
responded I've got really good responses
and not just like necessarily like
positive like wow amazing trip but also
like it seems to have hit a lot of
people in a way that a lot of shows
haven't um which is really cool and it's
something that I feel very lucky to have
been a part of and it's interesting as
well because I think I think we set out
not necessarily to make like the best
show of the most award-winning show or
anything like that it was more just to
make a show that would promote
discussion or instigate kind of
conversation about particular issues and
I feel like that's kind of what we've
done so it's cool it's really cool yeah
yeah I mean same for me like all the
things she said but also like people who
have talked to me and said I've only
heard from people who said that it's
really helped them out on their friends
and it's really amazing to hear those
responses from people you know nobody's
thoughts or opinions on shows that
address these topics are invalid because
there's no invalid thoughts about it but
you know I'm just glad that it's really
bringing these discussions to the
mainstream and they really haven't been
before I mean enough so I'm just
thrilled that we we reached our goal in
that sense so
you